in order to exist as a living system in
order to have form and to like to have
some kind of structure that's relatively
separate from the world around you need
to be
you need to attempt to know what's going
on around you otherwise you're just
going to get demolished by all the
forces in the world that you know
that demolished all the things that
aren't alive right um
and this this is not currently the kind
of way that most people think about
consciousness
in the kind of scientific and
philosophical mainstream we have this
like
hangover from uh well it's the kind of
whole
lineage of western thought where we kind
of assume that single-celled organisms
are just little mechanisms they're like
little clockwork things that just kind
of do their thing
and it's a very kind of um it's a view
that really takes away
any of the kind of or what a like vast
universe of complexity
like a single cell is you know so you
you'll hear scientists on the one hand
almost dismiss plants and single cells
as these
boring little mechanisms and yeah on the
other hand like life is the kind of one
of the greatest mysteries in the world
and we're talking about
life when we talk about a bacteria or a
single cell right um
so so yeah my the the simple way of
saying the theory is exactly as you said
that
it's really as simple as every living
system
uh which is a system that actively keeps
itself together
actively perpetuates its form it has to
attempt to know
what's going on in its environment it
needs to know of itself in this
environment
um and this is just another way of
saying consciousness it it kind of
okay it constructs beliefs about what's
going on like in existence in
in kind of a qualitative picture of the
world um
and this is we're talking now at a kind
of conceptual level but
which is how it first came to me but
then it turns out if you if you dig into
the kind of hard
like physics and like statistical
physics and maths behind the
thermodynamics of life
it's there the same stuff is there you
can unpack it at that level as well
and it was it was that when i saw that i
was like okay like this is
this i this isn't just hand waving you
know saying oh maybe
maybe that's how where consciousness is
i'm i'm actually convinced now that this
is
someone's opinion may contradict yours
where's my friend alan
it's all about your perspective who are
we
and what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host alan
sakyan very pumped for this episode we
are going to be talking about the living
mere
theory of consciousness we have dr
james cook joining us on the show hi
james
hey there it's great to be here thanks
for coming on the program i'm
very pumped for this episode for those
who don't know james's background
he's a neuroscientist writer and speaker
focusing on
consciousness meditation psychedelic
states reconciling
science and spirituality he posits the
living mere theory of
consciousness that all living things
need to know their world
he splits his time between london and
the mountains of portugal where he is
building a retreat
center at the surrender homestead you
can find his links in the buy below dr
jamescook.com
also his youtube page is housing having
great interviews right now and great
content check that out and he's writing
on reality sandwich all those links are
in the bio below
james let's start things off with
obviously you and i are both extremely
passionate about the synthesis of
science and spirituality
metaphysics understanding the nature of
reality the nature of consciousness
we're taking at it from such similar and
also slightly different perspectives
which is
this is going to be an epic back and
forth on that i loved
the learning about the living mirror
theory of consciousness and
especially the understanding from
from what i understood from your video i
liked
the fact that you went all the way back
to what you could say is
a biogenesis and just the i
the idea that you you can't divide
uh the cell from the cell's
understanding of its environment those
two things are coupled together if you
don't divide those things you understand
the unity of everything
but that's this general idea is that the
the living system
needs to understand its world will you
take us through that that process and
elaborate a bit
yeah definitely and so the way you said
it is perfect like the fact that
in order to exist as a living system in
order to have form and to like to have
some kind of structure that's relatively
separate from the world around you need
to be
you need to attempt to know what's going
on around you otherwise you're just
going to get demolished by all the
forces in the world
that you know that demolish all the
things that aren't alive right
um and this this is not currently the
kind of way that most people think about
consciousness
in the kind of scientific and
philosophical mainstream we have this
like
hangover from uh well it's the kind of
whole
lineage of western thought where we kind
of assume that single-celled organisms
are just little mechanisms they're like
little clockwork things that just kind
of do their thing
and it's a very kind of um it's a view
that really takes away any of the kind
of or
what a like vast universe of complexity
like a
single cell is you know so you you'll
hear scientists on the one hand
almost dismiss plants and single cells
as these
boring little mechanisms and yeah on the
other hand like life is the kind of one
of the greatest mysteries in the world
and we're talking about
life when we talk about a bacteria or a
single cell right um
so so yeah my the the simple way of
saying the theory is exactly as you said
that
it's really as simple as every living
system
uh which is a system that actively keeps
itself together
actively perpetuates its form it has to
attempt to know
what's going on in its environment it
needs to know of itself in its
environment
um and this is just another way of
saying consciousness it kind of
it constructs beliefs about what's going
on like in existence in
in kind of a qualitative picture of the
world um
and this is we're talking now at a kind
of conceptual level but
which is how it first came to me but
then it turns out if you if you dig into
the kind of hard
like physics and like statistical
physics and maths behind the
thermodynamics of life
it's there the same stuff is there you
can unpack it at that level as well
and it was it was that when i saw that i
was like okay like this is
this this isn't just hand waving you
know saying oh maybe
maybe that's how where consciousness is
i'm i'm utterly convinced now that this
is the um
as you say abiogenesis the moment the
life pops into existence that is the
moment the consciousness pops into
existence
because then you have a system that can
be aware before then
everything is just truly one system
where everything is dissolving into
everything else and you can't really
point to an object
and say is that conscious because you
know we can label a rock in the ocean as
a rock in the ocean
but really there's no boundary there
it's just being dissolved and
everything's
just kind of you know um melting into
each other in this kind of
in this kind of single thing we call
physical reality and so you can't
even say as a rock conscious but you can
point to the pattern of life
and say is that conscious um so there's
also
i think that's something i've not spoken
about in public but i think it's quite a
powerful
way of thinking about this life forms
with life forms you can even you can ask
if they're conscious
with everything else you can't even
really ask if it's conscious
in the ultimate nature of
this infinite consciousness this god the
source this implicate
whatever the that we want to use as that
as the main metaphysical uh truth
that within that ocean is that infinite
is a whirlpool and we've
been using this whirlpool analogy that
there's this whirlpool which is the
abiogenesis
for the whole planet and then there are
these whirlpools for all 8 billion
human creatures as well and that the
whirlpool itself
is the formation of the
the the coupling of the
uh the the the single-celled organism
at the first time to its environment the
coupling of that
there needs to be a ledger mechanism in
a sense
like i i really like using a ledger or
um idea because the cell itself
has a ledger when we've had uh
dr chow tong on the show and he is
extremely
obsessed with these these
these the mathematics of understanding
cells
because they do have a cycle they have a
schedule for mitosis they
they must know they have a protein
buildup that signals to them
at which point it's safe to divide um
given their memory and their history and
so there
without a doubt the same idea applies
to us do i have enough
resources right now for me to procreate
if the answer is
no i'm i'm not going to procreate there
will not be
uh mating and uh and further
the recursive function of making more
humans and so
the this this idea that your life
is is inextricably connected to the
to your environment and now did you
choose the word um mirror because
of how it's all in a sense we talk about
this so much in in spiritual
world where if it is just this one
consciousness that is having the
the symphonic experience through all
eight billion
artists and that there's that we're all
in a sense
mirrors of the same source and so is
that the idea that both the mirror
of the individual and their environment
like that
there's that coupling together of the of
the
ledger of the person in their
environment but also the mirroring of
all eight billion
of us of that source
yeah so so i would say that the um the
word mirror
is referring to a kind of property of
the living system but the consciousness
itself is like a reflection
so if you want to understand a
reflection
you know the analogy would be for
neuroscientists trying to understand
consciousness by just looking at the
brain in isolation
it would be like studying the surface of
a mirror and trying to figure out what
all these patterns are
like you can't if you refuse to think
about photons and you refuse to think
about how they reflect off of other
surfaces
that then get reflected in the mirror
then you're not going to understand what
what a reflection is it's it's something
that can only be understood as a process
arising in this in this very zoomed out
picture
where you're considering the photons
you're considering the surface
properties of the mirror
um and so similarly with with living
systems when you zoom out and you see
living systems as as you say a kind of
whirlpool
as a pattern in reality um that
perpetuates itself
a feature of those patterns is that
there's this kind of informational
reflection
of the structure of the world around the
system inside it
and this is kind of what consciousness
is i would say
um and i think it's to go back to um
you were you were saying the kind of the
source or the kind of you know
i might call it the ground of being
right if we get into this kind of
these metaphysical questions um part of
the reason people have found it hard to
think about the place of consciousness
in nature
uh is kind of articulated by something
called the hard problem of consciousness
which can be thought of in a few
different ways but one way of thinking
about it
is as a metaphysical problem that you've
got the kind of hard matter that makes
up the world
and then there's a kind of substance
that exists and then you've got mind
which is kind of another substance and
somehow you've got a map between the two
uh if you look
at you know prior to this kind of um
this scientific narrative that the world
is made of little material building
blocks
most kind of spiritual traditions have
this idea that
the ground of being is something utterly
beyond our concepts
you can call it mata you can call it
consciousness you can call it whatever
you want but
it's it's utterly it's the ground like
the territory is so much greater and
vaster than the map the these little
words we say are nothing
in the face of the kind of the source of
existence
like like saying that we're crickets
imagining the big game
yeah exactly right and so that's why god
is actually you know coming from a kind
of scientist who's not a kind of um
a theist or anything like the word the
word god is useful because it points to
the fact that well what does god mean
it's another word but it points to
something utterly
beyond words right utterly transcendent
eminent and everything
um and so i actually have a kind of pet
peeve i think in in
kind of spiritual communities when we
use the word consciousness for the kind
of
um for this ground of being because
we're now just
instead of say instead of really sitting
with the fact that the ground of being
is truly
beyond words if we say it's
consciousness
then we're kind of it feels like we it's
tempting to give it a label right
but i think it can get confusing because
i would say if you think the ground of
being is consciousness then you would
think
in that perspective that at the big bang
there was some experience i'm saying
the kind of grounded being is some
mysterious process and the big bang was
not a conscious event
it was it was unconscious kind of things
happening um
and consciousness exists in these kind
of reflections of living
living systems so it's it's not that
everything is in consciousness in my
world view
um but it's important to understand that
uh
the world isn't divided fundamentally
into matter and mind
everything is processed everything is
just this this kind of strange creative
thing
unfolding which is what we see in
quantum mechanics if you try and say
where is that subatomic particle
good luck it's nowhere it doesn't have a
look at a pre-existing location
because you're part of this kind of web
of co-creation
you know and what we call mata is not
this pre-existing stage it's this
this kind of yeah this process that gets
co-created and
consciousness is also a process and so i
think that's why you can offer
scientific theories of consciousness
because all sciences is another map it's
a map of the territory
and we can come up with a map that
describes how mata behaves we can come
up with a map that describes how
consciousness behaves and how they fit
together and i see no problem there
yeah beautiful so we are
constantly trying to make better
and better maps of the
reality yet the the most simple way to
say it is that there is
a an indescribable this ineffable
um and then there is that
and there's a creative likely
likely an eternal creative
unfolding um and that the unfolding
has a feedback mechanism and the the
and that feedback mechanism is this this
co-creative
uh ability for us to
out of all of the infinite potential
that you have as an artist
that you get to pick what you want to
uh unfold in the in out of the infinite
potential what you want to collapse what
you want to
become so okay so an eternal
process now the the reason why it's
tempting i think to put
to subsume cosmogeny in
consciousness or infinite consciousness
is because there is
no in a sense nothing else
besides this experience
that we are having and that
in a sense consciousness is the tool
that we use
as from whatever perspective of that god
or source or whatever you want to call
that
from that indescribable we use
consciousness
as the tool to experience ourselves
i think my um so maybe my
take on this is that maybe you know
maybe because i'm a scientist that i i
want
the problem for me of of of
consciousness and also just as an
individual who meditates into this other
stuff
the problem for me is accounting for
this particular thing that is like
it's private it's this qualitative space
of awareness that's here right now and
you have it right
and we're going to give that the label
consciousness and we're going to face
this as a problem like where does that
emerge in nature right
so that's that's one thing if if
all of existence is in consciousness or
it has consciousness or it
is conscious that's it could be a
similar kind of thing but but i think it
won't have exactly the same properties
it pretty much doesn't have like a
boundary and inside and outside like
oh yeah so oh yeah it's yes
it could be something related but we so
we
you know we could come up with a
speculative or metaphysical idea
of of the infinite consciousness but
then there's organism consciousness
yeah yeah and we're going to talk about
those differently right oh interesting
okay so as uh you know rupert spire
talks about this
and bernardo castro does as well there's
the screen the infinite
screen of of consciousness or awareness
and then on it is all of the
all these little perforated like
dissociative
um private uh consciousnesses
and that uh organism consciousness as
you said
and uh i like i kind of like that you
know if we were to make some sort of a
division of this one
into two it would be interesting to do
it like a a metaphysical consciousness
that's indescribable and then
like a little private or organisms
consciousness in the whirlpools
that's kind of interesting yeah okay and
that kind of takes it from a scientific
side
as well it and i i yeah yeah which is
very important i
i agree with this uh process i i
totally agree i i've lived too um
much in san francisco
and the bay area is like spiritual as
community
where there's a very strong um tendency
to um kind of just go with whatever new
age
impulse arises and that it's it's very
important to
um it both embody whatever that
intuition is but also
embody the science that comes along with
it so
yeah yeah i mean i think for me
it's again it may be uh yeah i you know
if i spend my whole life in science this
might be just an interesting difference
between
you know putting uh our environmental
factors might be
what's what's kind of bringing up our
differences um
yeah our differences on this on this
topic and um
i do think there's a kind of
fundamentally like i
i guess i i've always been fascinated by
kind of
describing uh these things as part of
nature
you know nature is this like yeah it's
almost like spinoza had this idea like
nature is god effectively like it
doesn't need to be a personal god with
like
anything like that but it's this it's
just this lawful
beautiful like thing that's that's
that's far bigger than us
and so that's my kind of my scientific
perspective is like when it comes to
this
kind of speculative metaphysical
consciousness that might be bigger than
my
home consciousness um i guess i i kind
of
have to i you know i i don't i guess i
just draw the line there for myself as
and say my job
as the kind of spiritually engaged
neuroscientist is to think about
this consciousness but i can't i can't
speculate
about that stuff as much but also it's
because
my spiritual worldview is is also like i
you know in in like something like the
dao di ching he's like you know
it's it's all about how you know the
doubt that can be named is not the
eternal dao it's like
if you're going to try and describe this
thing by calling it anything
if you think you've got a handle on it
you're fooling yourself it's it's
so utterly beyond you know we can call
again metaphysical consciousness or
absolute infinite consciousness this
this is starting to get a vibe that it
sounds very big it sounds very grounded
it sounds like it's the right kind of
word
but then you have to realize that it's
going to be utterly it cannot
encapsulate the crowd of being like
so i quite like the spiritual side of me
just likes to kind of come up against
this mystery
and say like yeah like i don't i can't
know what this
thing is i think it's unknowable in its
essence um
and then the scientist in me is like
okay do i think there's a reason to
think the big bang was conscious of
itself
i can't see any kind of mechanism by
which that would happen so i'm going to
suspect no and that's when you start to
get into the
these kind of fascinating questions of
like what we might call organisms level
consciousness
which i guess i'm just calling
consciousness um yeah
this is so beautiful because
it's so extremely important to
embody the truth of mysterianism and
the idea of the eternal doubt that can
be named as the dow that can be named is
not the eternal dao
the idea that the more that you
both truly surrender to the essence of
the nature of reality
both very important but also
simultaneously
balancing that with the true
scientific spiritual inquiry
into what actually that is and like
you know eric weinstein calls it you
know the source code or and you know
really uncovering what that what that is
and
um you know hilbert talked about the the
importance of of of uncovering that like
we
must know and you know whatever you know
boom
was so focused on uncovering whatever
the implicat
is and like we must know and so
it's like this balance between we must
know and
and and probing at it with the
mysterianism
yeah yeah yeah i think i'm a big
advocate for
kind of reigning science in and putting
it in its place when it comes to you
know i
i think that um you know fundamentally
we're humans we're here we're having a
weird experience of of
existence and you know all of the kind
of
the feelings of awe and meaning and
stuff that's the first stuff that you
experience then a scientist might come
along and say okay let's try and do some
clever tricks to come up with good
stories that fit the world
and we do that game and i fell in love
with that game i think it's wonderful
um you know it clearly is it works very
well it's what's allowing us to talk
now um so it clearly gives us some kind
of knowledge
but it doesn't eradicate just this
immediate felt conscious sense of
here we are and spiritual experience
right this is for me is like the
spiritual experience
of meaning and all and and just
existence comes first
and then science is this quite should be
this humble storyteller it should be
something that you know and i guess i'm
describing science here as
i would say science and philosophy like
if you're going to make claims about the
world
try to do it as carefully and vigorously
and and uh honestly as possible
yeah and i think and i think that's why
i actually i'm very happy to stop
very stop short and say what is the
nature of
of the kind of ground of being i don't
have any tools for that i haven't got a
microscope to look at it i haven't got
philosophical tools to think about it um
and so i think i maybe stopped short
further sure than other people would in
in speculating about what it what it
could be and and yeah that's that's just
the place of
it's recognizing our limits there's
these kind of naked apes that came up
with these funny ways to figure out the
world
i would also plug here sri aurobindo and
the mother mir alfasa talk a lot about
the super irrational enigma that that it
truly is
and that it really does require a
when when you use the body itself
as the mechanism to intuitively
tap into the nature of reality there's
gonna be
better and better ways to scientifically
analyze the
biometric correlates of these sort of
awakened states
and that's gonna be a very interesting
way
for example when someone has
imperturbable peace and causeless joy
and
that's a sign of living in the infinite
that's a sign of
being god or the dao that's a sign of
being
truth and butterfly affecting it out and
that's a very you know spiritual
statement and scientists would be like
what do you mean by that let's do that
more
and i'm like yeah we can we can totally
play that that's that's very important
we must plant flags beyond the edge of
knowledge
and we must and this is what you know
richard feynman so many other scientists
have been doing this forever
is planting flags beyond what's known
and then in a sense hypo
making a hypothesis and then testing it
which we are we are going to do now
but the vedic rishis 5 000 years ago
parmenides and heraclitus
we're talking about guys that knew
and girls that knew the nature of being
at its most fundamental level by
leveraging
what is just existence phenomenological
awareness
as what they believe to be that
true nature of of of who we are and
and i think that i think that we must we
must realize that
science is that incredible
tool set that that is very important to
making a map and to understanding um
enabling incredible things like this and
then
to also um enable the other
tool to to help which is in a sense this
spirituality this like we ca like we
we the we can't
we can't choke the god in
man along the way um we ha we have to
enable the god and man to flourish at
the same time
i want to ask this this question this
has been a
a great back and forth there i really
liked how we talked about
some sort of a if we were to break it
into two
this like metaphysical first principled
consciousness with this
organism consciousness i think that's a
very interesting
way to to break that um down let's um
let's let's have you explain this so
we have a living mirror theory of
consciousness we have
a an uh something that can absolutely
not be decoupled we
the the the way that the the the way
that the
individual consciousness the private
consciousness the organism consciousness
the way that that becomes exists
is literally through the fact that it
must understand its world it must
understand its environment and it has
it has an ongoing feedback loop where
it's
air food water um
fitness functions always fitness
functions
um reproduction um ideas ideas ideas
what are the ideas at the top of the
fitness landscape how can i consume
those ideas to make me as
as smart as possible um so i can etc so
is this kind of your general reasoning
over those billions of years and how
that
is slowly what had been happening
yeah i mean that that's an excellent
description of it and um but what i
would say is that
you're right that it can't be decoupled
so the moment that
life comes into existence there's
full-blown consciousness there's
full-blown awareness of an environment
and it wouldn't be as
complex as ours you know if you don't
have a retina made up of loads of cells
and all this other complexity
your the contents are not going to be as
complex as ours
but the fact of experience is is the
fact of experience and to me this
is um so there's no uh change in
consciousness
over the course of evolution if you
could trade if you could have your atoms
rearranged into a single-celled organism
you would be experiencing the world as
vividly as you are now
um it'd be a very different experience
but there'd still be um
an experience of that and i think
something that's um
so in this picture because consciousness
is this kind of absolute
pristine perfect kind of space in which
all
experiences arise it even though it
seems to be separated
you know there are these different
islands of consciousness right now
there's at least one over here and
there's
there's one where you are the character
of consciousness itself
is the same it can only ever be the same
so it's like
if you imagine you know as as these
creatures engaging in survival dynamics
we become very
concerned with our separation i become
very concerned to differentiate myself
from you
and you know in order to survive and so
the separation becomes
the really important thing but if you
try and kind of zoom out and look
objectively
you can kind of imagine if we're all
like soap bubbles like we're made out of
of the same liquid the dynamics of
evolution and survival would make us
obsessed with our separation
but we're all made of the same liquid
this consciousness is the same
consciousness
it's a feature of the universe it's not
my it's not james's consciousness the
concept of james in my head
does not possess consciousness the
organism doesn't even possess
consciousness because it's arising
through the interaction with the
environment so it's more like you have a
single universe
with a sprinkling of islands of
consciousness it's like
it's like a bunch of eyes opening in one
in one organism you think of the
universe as this organism and where each
of us is like an eye
opening in it and in that way you can
see why in this picture consciousness is
still
this unified thing and you can still um
you can t you can feel yourself
identified with that rather than
your own your own personal consciousness
and if you imagine
once you have that kind of experience of
realizing that
you know this is usually described as
the self being an illusion in spiritual
circles when you when you realize that
and you recognize
this character of consciousness then the
moment you die
another eye will open in the universe
somewhere right and and in parallel
there are now these
multiple eyes opening and when you
identify with with that process
then you realize okay i really am that
ground of being i really am the
that that um just the unfolding of the
world and
these these eyes opening in it um which
i think i think
when i read texts like the vaders and
and the tao and things like this
i um to me it it fits with my the
wardrobe i'm describing i i guess
there are some that are quite explicit
about kind of mind only only
consciousness existing
but to me i i i get the feeling that the
the authors of these texts were seeing
the same world view where a rock doesn't
have to be conscious the big bang didn't
have to be conscious
if they're aware of the big bang um but
it describes these these principles you
know even reincarnation right if you
take
the buddhist idea of reincarnation with
the idea you know the central one of the
central doctrines of buddhism is the
self is an illusion
so i don't think you can think of it as
james is reincarnated
but when you have this recognition of
the selflessness of consciousness
then it's like well what's really
happening is you know to use rupert
spire's term of the screen of perception
or of consciousness
it's like there's this movie of james
happening and then there might be a
movie of a frog happening
in parallel and then after i die as well
and then a plant and
the screen is always the same i
absolutely agree with that that the
character of consciousness is identical
and i think to really grasp you know the
pace of consciousness in nature you
really
need to be familiar with that and that's
why you know you can see it as this
binary event
as soon as you have these enclosed
living systems you have consciousness
um instead of a lot of scientific
thinking gets kind of confused with
wakefulness and sleeping and like and
then things have levels of consciousness
and
and that's where people start to think
well maybe it gradually evolved but then
the philosophers are like no there's
there's no way it could have gradually
evolved that that can't possibly have
happened and
yeah so i think i think this the kind of
spiritual perspective is actually really
crucial in understanding the place of
the scientific picture of where
consciousness fits in nature
wow okay so there's
there's a there's a coexistence that
it's always so important like shirobindo
talked about this so much
just the utter refusal to cut life in
two and to divide it in two and that if
you always
keep it at that one and no matter how
you perceive
always at the one it'll always help and
especially
in this sense like i think that the idea
of
an evolution just exists
it just plainly is true but also
at the same time again simultaneity
being key
where it's like obviously we didn't have
a way to structure meaning we couldn't
structure order out of the chaos
as well as we do now that's just fact we
just didn't have that ability to do it
and now we're structuring order
significantly more out of the chaos
okay so there's that so there has been
some sort of an evolution
of this negative this neg entropy
and now we have this and it's excellent
okay great so there's that it's like the
whirlpool has
had is you know this the the eternal
spiral
but the you know we're here but then at
the same time
is that we're holding that perspective
at the same time as we're holding
the infinite screen of the of
consciousness and that
that itself is never changing parmenidus
and heraclitus really had
from what i understand this first like 2
500 years ago the first realization of
both of those things
coexisting at the same time and
the that eternal becoming and the
eternal being
at the same time and like if you never
divide in two then you get to that yeah
yeah yeah and that's exactly so the way
i would say in
my picture of the world is that in order
to be an island of consciousness in
order to have this kind of
you know this perfect peaceful perch of
awareness
from which you can just kind of sit and
observe the world you know in the kind
of in the best kind of
meditative states you know if you can
achieve that um where
there is just this kind of yeah it's
pristine
peaceful consciousness in order to have
that
privilege of being able to look out of
the world and have the lights turn on
you need to struggle
you need to struggle to keep yourself
together do you there needs to be this
this controlling and trying to make
order to happen
and it's kind of like that's just the
price of of admission like that's that's
the bind we find ourselves in
and it's better to kind of come to terms
with that sooner rather than later
and it's also why i actually don't why i
don't tend to think about there being
some kind of
um consciousness outside of outside of
this process because if there was
not to be too dark but there would be no
point in me continuing to live
if i could live not as an organism that
didn't have to feel pain and didn't have
to feel hunger and all this stuff
and i could still be conscious and at
that i could be part of an infinite
blissful kind of unified consciousness
then that seems better like i don't see
this seems to be a mistake
this this evolution thing this life
thing it seems like a silly
like you know we're going to return to
the one and then be like why did we do
that stupid game that was that game
was sucked it just introduced suffering
um whereas in my
picture of the world it's like yeah this
this this funny situation we find
ourselves in that it's an amazing
privilege to be alive but it's not free
it it's not trivial
it's a it's a truly kind of interesting
place to find ourselves in i think yeah
sri aurobindo
says that becoming
is the only being and
and i think that's this is a very
interesting one
to put it is that what whatever the
the the infinite is is
only becoming an infinite amount of ways
and and that that exactly could be and
this is kind of where i'm honing
in on the logic of the infinite i'm
trying again
the cricket trying to imagine the big
game but i do think that the logic
of the infinite is that it must
validate the fact that it is infinite
and that it does so by creating an
infinite amount of illusory
affinity and that we are that
you know tatvam asi we are that
i and my father are one the more
that you realize and embody the fact
that if this is true
that we are the publishers of
this and the more that you realize that
we are the publishers
and the players and that here we are
playing
i think the more you live from truth the
more you live from
and when you and like you described
earlier as well
when you realize that the one eye
the one i one i
that is experiencing it itself
from through all through all of us
and that the more that you embody that
realization if it can
you know like adi ashanti calls it you
know the flickering you know you get the
light it flickers a little you're like
oh and then and then like slowly
um it does it it is in a sense like you
said it's it's a death and a rebirth
it's a
it's a caterpillar into a butterfly if
that
light went that light and that's what it
seems like we're evolving towards
is that light permanently
staying on that's when the being
can the individual artist can no longer
ever ever have any violence
or even negativity not let yeah
violence at worst negativity at even the
most
minuscule malevolence towards another
because it's you and then if we can get
there as
as a planet that's that's i think this
this main key of the where where we're
heading yeah i mean i and also you said
if it's true
that we are the publisher as well as the
player i would say it's definitely true
like there's no
way that we are not the same physical
stuff of the universe and
and there's no way that the self is what
we think it is you know to
to think that you are not the main event
of
that you are not the same thing as the
kind of ground of being that illusion
kind of comes about because we take
this story we tell ourselves of
separation very very seriously right
but i think the the idea of the infinite
as well is really relevant because i
think i think they're
we've touched on it in like two
different ways i think um
and there's the first way in in the
sense that which also relates to the
idea
why i'm not i don't believe that
consciousness is the kind of crown of
being
is the only way the only kind of
speculative way i can think about
as as to why this is happening right now
like why are we why is this going on why
are we here
would be that the kind of default of
reality
if you if you have no boundaries nothing
going on like nothing to hem reality and
then it's infinity right like that's
kind of just the default
if you're going to make no assumptions
you could say there was consciousness in
the beginning but then you're like well
where did that come from
what gave it that structure but if you
just say there's
if you say nothing effectively there's
infinity and in infinity
everything that can happen will happen
all the you know things will start
happening
patterns will emerge and at some point
those patterns become these patterns
that open their eyes and go what the
hell is
going on yes um so that's my picture of
the world is it's a lawful
unfolding that can be understood um and
there is no the infinity is the
beginning there is no
it's not like there was some some being
with structure who thought
i'm going to will all this into
existence i think it's just happening
and it will happen forever because yeah
you can't cut
you just you can't come up with an end
to infinity yeah it doesn't make sense
yeah um and you can also connect with
that by
before like kind of sinking into the
present moment recognizing your being
now
you're the nature of your mind you know
if you say consciousness is infinite to
the
to the average person like well you know
you might be meaning it in the sense of
it is the kind of infinite ground of
being but if i say consciousness
has this quality of infinity i what i
mean is it's not finite
it's not actually bounded into concepts
in the way we think it is
we think it's divided and structured and
but it's actually not it's it's
i was maybe it's maybe you should coin a
new term like a finite or something as
opposed to
infinite um because infinite has this
kind of i guess idea of like spatial
extension and stuff
but if it's just it's not finite um and
when you recognize that yourself you do
connect with
with this ground of being and i totally
get why you know in the best
in the kind of deepest moments of
meditation you have this
feeling of consciousness just kind of
beholding
existence and there being this wordless
getting
you just kind of you get it in a way
that you can't with words and it's
if you were going to try and put in
words it is something like oh you're me
like but then that's not quite right
because there there is no me so it's
more like
it is like is or something like that
right if you if you wanted to
but wasn't it and i see why from there
because that's happening in
consciousness
it's tempting to think well maybe this
consciousness is me and this
consciousness is everything
and i think that's where metaphysically
people can kind of differ but we should
all be humble i guess
is because like i will make claims about
what we can't say and what we can say
and ultimately we're we're really way
out we're in deep waters here
i think you know we're trying to label
this stuff
oh i love this love this chase so let's
um
let's hit uh what you're going to
be uh releasing do you have the journal
of consciousness studies
and we have that um so
tell us about what like what is um
how do we test that like the hypothesis
because we've been
you know yeah we've been talking about
it so much
um living mirrors theory so what what do
we
do for um
proper like is there a randomized
control trial like
yeah yeah and or do we have to use
simulation technology to
to like yeah yeah yeah go ahead good
so yeah i would say computational
modeling like simulating
and um would be one step but that's
going to be
i mean you know technology is increasing
exponentially right so maybe it's not
that far away
right now the simulations we can do are
so puny we can't simulate a single cell
like it that it's too complex as a
single cell um
but we can do kind of quite simple
simulations with this stuff
um so what would be nice would be to be
able to simulate a single cell
um and then so say you have a bacteria
and you could effectively simulate based
on the statistical physics the patterns
in its environment
it's the fight you you find out its
fitness functions and you model
what you think its structure of its
consciousness should be like you know
what dimensions of kind of
photo you know of like light
sensitivities they have and then you do
behavioral experiments where you would
you would basically test it flashlights
make it respond for nutrients and stuff
and just see like does the theory
predict the structure of consciousness
and that would be the kind of gold
standard way of really
you know it's not a um i guess yeah in
that in that picture you would be able
to just see like
do does it fall out of the theory does
it match up if it doesn't match up the
theory is probably not right
um but the other kind of more gradual
approach which is similar
is that the the actual
um the kind of mathematical basis of the
theory is not some
um kind of fringe you know bit of
bit of science it's actually the
emerging mainstream picture of how the
brain works
is it's been described as kind of a
hierarchical inference it's like this
idea of the bayesian brain it's what's
called the free energy principle
all of this stuff is is about using
exactly the same mathematics as applies
to the single cell
um to understand how the brain works and
this this was
best fleshed out by a guy called
coffiston uh his neuroscientist at the
same university as me
he's done some wonderful work here and
and this is to me is
you know more and more people are lining
up to think of the brain in these terms
and so the the lyric mirror theory just
fits
perfectly alongside it it just says here
whilst you're doing your neuroscience
studies in the human brain
as well as just saying okay i know a
human brain is conscious
but i don't know what to say about any
other living system this theory gives
you a way of saying well alongside your
experiments you can say
this is a way of thinking about which
systems are conscious why they're
conscious when you know where in the
universe they're conscious
and so what i hope is that people will
gradually just kind of in the same way
with
the theory of evolution people there was
no there was no experiment to test
it really but the kind of gradual just
seeing how it made sense of everything
it just fit with
all the data everyone gradually was like
oh okay this is the right way of
thinking about it
that's where i'm at personally with
being like okay as someone who's
always been passionate about trying to
understand the mystery of consciousness
you know i've read the different things
on offer and they don't they just don't
sit right with me if they had sat right
with me
you know i would have stuck with those
but i mean this isn't controversial no
one
you know yeah we're not in a situation
where we think consciousness is solved
right like
um there is nothing wherever it's like
yep this is definitely the answer
so that would be my um my hope but the
problem is that it really hinges on
the the radical change in humanity in
the kind of consciousness of humanity
that you described like well you know
having more people realize
what they really are there's there's a
sense in which
so we spoke about the idea that there is
this evolutionary process there is kind
of becoming and and we get more and more
ability to create order and control the
world
and that's what's kind of got us to
where we are now
but we're living so much in that side of
things we're living so much in
separation and control that we have
these
you know societies that are structured
around
progress progress progress you know use
humans as machines to kind of
to generate more material stuff and
and we're not balanced enough into the
kind of being side of things
when you when you're in the kind of you
know the being side of things
that's when you can look at a plant and
say oh you're me like we're the same
thing
i totally gathered you would be
conscious so i think most humans have
this kind of
tunnel vision of separation where after
generation
and generation of going on this kind of
progress mode
with all of its kind of feelings of
trauma and being distant from the rest
of the natural world
we feel like that the punchline of
consciousness has to be
that we are special that we are
different that our separation
our felt separation from nature is a
good thing ultimately because we are
it's what gives us our consciousness
it's you know we're these these
truly different things but i i think
we're just that perspective is one of
this kind of stress traumatized
dissociation and tunnel vision
and if we all come back into just being
we recognize our unity with nature we
we would look at a plant and recognize
it as an extension of the same thing
that created us
and suddenly you're like oh okay i get
it plants can be conscious that totally
makes sense and we see this in people
who
engage in spiritual practice or after
psychedelics and they really kind of see
through the kind of the delusional
structures and consciousness for what
consciousness really is
and they're brought into this being mode
more um
yeah and i think if so i think actually
peop widespread if it turns out i'm true
my theory is true or i'm correct i think
the limiting factor will be
that perspective will be people having a
kind of knee-jerk reaction of like no
ways
is that true because i my feeling of
separation is i'm so attached to it
same same thing with darwin and
evolution right it's like don't tell me
i'm the same as an ape like
i don't like to hear that because i have
this real feeling of like
not being at peace and struggling and
being separate um
so yeah it's quite a maybe unlike this
is why consciousness is such a tricky
thing to address i think because it's so
close to home we have
it's not only to do with what we are is
to do with what reality is
and so we have such emotional investment
in in what this answer is and whether it
satisfies us
that i think um unlike other problems
there's yeah that could be a big
boundary to whether or not it's ever
accepted as as correct but also could be
wrong
two ways uh to hit the ball back there
the first one is uh yeah super
eloquently
described with the tunnel vision of
separation and that
slowly becoming more and more augmented
and awakened uh
and harmonized especially between
um the importance of seeing the the
collective symphony
at the same time as seeing a unique gift
and artistic contribution those two
things together are critical
and then on the first part that you
mentioned let's talk about the
mathematics
here i think this is very interesting
chow tong when we had him on the show in
china
he was so um insightful
and visionary about the fact that we are
literally going to need
new math to understand how life works
and i think that's so profoundly
interesting because
like you described even given such
extreme
successes with computational capacities
how do we
actually simulate the inner workings of
even a single cell and how it interacts
with its environment
and then how we can basically prove the
idea is that that you can prove there's
like a mathematics of
consciousness of that cell that when it
does
get a like a light source as an
input that it does register that and
that it makes an
output and that that's the idea of
a of a of a of an attempt
at a a deeper living mirror theory
of understanding and how a multi-cell
organism has
like a slightly more complex
mathematical
computation of its of understanding it's
of its environment
is that the general trajectory alongside
what mainstream is yeah
i think where we're currently at the
maths is is coming along
well actually like so this again this is
mainly the work of cole fristen and
what's called the free energy principle
um and the existing state of it is i
mean it is complicated
maths um and so it's but it's it's not
um
you know it's it's it's not like
inventing a whole new branch of
mathematics i guess
but it's uh fundamentally the the idea
is that
if that in order to exist you need to
minimize the kind of disorder in your
boundary if you don't minimize the
disorder in your boundary you're not
going to exist you're going to dissolve
into it and if you look at that kind of
physically
the mathematics describe that physically
it's the same you can rearrange it
and it basically says that it's the same
as what's called bayesian inference
which is
again this i mentioned the bayesian
brain the idea that this is just a kind
of branch of mathematics that's to do
with
how you build models of the world how
you test it against um hypotheses
how you test your hypotheses against
data and in my
in my theory what i should actually make
clear is that
the math describes the the contents of
consciousness the structure
so in this picture you'd be able to say
okay that primate with its three
different types of photoreceptors or
color sensor photoreceptors
has trichromatic vision it has these
kind of three dimensions of color and we
can map out this kind of structure
the fact of consciousness is not
something that can be
you know it that's where you need to
zoom out to this kind of
to the universe really to the picture of
the environment and the organism
and like a reflection it exists in the
interaction between the
the organism and its environment so the
question of to go back to
what you said before about can ever be
proven the idea you would never be able
to prove
this organism has consciousness this
organism doesn't have consciousness
this is just you know one of the
features of consciousness is private
right and i can speculate that you have
it because your physiology is so similar
to mine
it would be really unsurprising it'd be
very surprising if you had a similar
you're a similar organism without
consciousness that would just see it
would seem so
so weird that i'm willing to grant it to
you um
and then with a theory you can start to
think okay i'm willing to grant it to
these other
organisms for these reasons but there
can never be
i can never prove that you're not a
robot you know like or a zombie is the
kind of philosophical term for being
with no without consciousness um and so
the mathematics
would really be making progress in terms
of cashing out
whether we've got a handle on how the
contents are structured but then if
if the theory manages to pull that off
then
it's good to assume that it's it's right
in some fundamental way
okay so living mere theory is heavily
grounded in the mathematics of the
uh structure of consciousness
well no so i would say the basic insight
is
is just the conceptual one we said
before you can really
we could not talk about thermodynamics
at all we could just say if you're going
to exist
you need to know what's going on around
you and i think for some people they
might think yeah that makes sense
like that's a that makes more sense than
maybe
i don't know saying if your brain
oscillates at 40 hertz then you're
conscious that seems that doesn't seem
to hold any
intuition so so so is the explanation is
it is it then
fair to say that it's the mathematics of
the living system and the way that it is
coupled with its environment
yes yes so so the mathematics only comes
in
when it when you know it was it's a
scientific theory so if you want a
tester you want to
you want to get precise that's where it
comes in but you don't need to worry
about
the actual kind of okay that level of
granularity
to to feel you've got a handle on what
i'm what i'm claiming
yeah yeah correct that's kind of where
we started um
is having the handle on it without the
math but then i see where um where
because i'm so interested in the actual
process of getting
people around the world to go okay
what we're triangulating on and what
five thousand plus years of metaphysical
lineages on consciousness across the
world
are triangulating on is the exact same
thing
and um that that's why um i i want
the math to succeed i want the
hypotheses
to be uh proven over time
uh and successfully
uh over and over and over again
um yeah and that's why i ask about the
math and
and the complicated process of doing the
simulations
of the coupling of the living system
with its
um environment and then kind of like
the idea is that the math you're we're
in a sense we're watching
the changes of the math
we're watching those changes to
determine
in consciousness you mean yeah yeah yeah
that's interesting i mean it gets a bit
uh i need to be careful because if it's
like you're watching it's like you're
conscious of
these other things so i would say i
would say the maths is
the math and the theory are always just
maps for the territory right so
this is a picture where it's not like
consciousness is just information
processing it's not like the computer
analogy for the brain where
you just assume it's this very thin kind
of uh description of what's going on
it's really a body it's like you have
this real
like existence that's happening right
now and it's a real process
and when you have a system that believes
things about
in about the world around it this is
what it feels like um
and the theory and and mathematical
descriptions are just
maps they're just saying here's how it
should play out if we've got a really if
we've got a
angle on what's going on this is what it
what it should look like um
so the consciousness itself is is
embodied in the world
and this then the theories are just
their descriptions they're they're a
language game ultimately
um which is why if you if you forced me
to choose between science and
spirituality i would choose to just
meditate the rest of my life away
instead of
the the game of trying to put it into
words and
in other forms of language is not as uh
it's not as real it's it's a story it's
ultimately a story
interesting okay all right um i think
that's a really solid
amount on um on living
mir theory let's um
let's play a little bit on um
the telos uh i just want to play on this
for a bit given the fact that we're
talking about simulation tech we're
given
ai vr tech emerging
what's being unleashed with quantum
computation
so ultimately it seems as though the way
that
a tree drops seeds and those become
trees in the way that a zygote makes a
human and humans procreate make more
humans
um the same way that a big bang makes a
civilization and we make more big bangs
do you see the recursion as the telos
um do you see this as a quine in a sense
by telos do you mean some kind of like
purpose to the to the whole thing
yeah yeah i i think um
i mean i guess i my view the recursion
comes in the kind of self-referential
nature of things comes in with life
and with it's crucial for consciousness
with you know
because we're we're kind of
self-starting creatures
we're um there is no we're both the
puppeteer and the puppet you know of our
of ourselves
uh but i see i think i see
that's actually really interesting
because i i would say that i see the
evolution of the universe
starting at the big bang as rather than
a kind of recursive process as quite a
kind of linear
process like a kind of like a radial
process of like a flower
blooming or something where you have a
big bang and then you have physics
becoming becoming chemistry becoming
biology becoming
like just increasing complexity and it's
but it's this very um
i don't know aesthetically i like it as
well it makes me feel very like
reassured that the world is just moving
in one direction and
and it makes things feel less loopy and
and complicated
than the kind of quiet coin picture
because when you when you start
interesting consciousness you really
can't tumble down
you know holes of solipsism and you know
not knowing whether where the kind of
flaw is um of reality
but i would say yeah actually when it
comes to
so when it comes to reality itself
there's a sense in which we kind of
touched on earlier
you know newton had this idea that
everything the universe is made of
little separate things little separate
bricks they're truly separate
and then with quantum mechanics we now
know it's far more like an interwoven
tapestry
or like a house of cards where every
kind of piece is dependent
on all the other pieces and
consciousness is like that as well
i think this is how you can get
consciousness arising out of a physical
system because it's not like it
introduces a new substance into
existence
but at the level of information a system
can hold that the world is one way as
opposed to another way
it can hold that something as hot versus
cold but then there are correlations
with like
well hot things tend to be more red and
yellow you know there's like long
wavelengths of light rather than kind of
blues and greens
in this kind of self-referential process
you build up consciousness you
you you get this kind of house of cards
of more this less of that
and this is kind of touched on the
buddhist concept of emptiness when you
in the west we have ideas of qualia the
idea that redness is a thing like
the idea of quality was supposed to be
like an atom of consciousness which
i think should sound like a kind of
nonsense idea red is only red
with respect to everything else in
consciousness you can't isolate it and
have just
just read um and so this is the buddhist
concept of emptiness that if you really
look at red for long enough
it loses any sense of any intrinsic
essence it's all just this kind of
mirage of
of relative relative change so i'd say
in that sense
i don't know if that's precisely the way
you mean this kind of this kind of
self-referential structure but i think
yeah everything emerges in this in this
way and it and it's part it's a feature
of a holistic
picture of things the holistic nature of
consciousness and the holistic nature of
the physical world as well
in inevitably it's going to happen
with the west becoming
uh more and more and even china
you know japan is a canary in the coal
mine in many ways with
humans passing i don't know if you've
seen the husk
but the husk is the the contraption now
for
for the ultimate uh unit where you're
literally
just you know you got your bed you got
your
computer you got your controller your
your you know you got your whole
setup and and soon it's just you know
it's right in it's it's
it's connected directly in and and
you're
it if you don't put on vr
and use it for 30 minutes
and then take it off and think to
yourself
how am i not already in vr
then you don't know but if you do have
that process
you take it off and you in and you make
the
self-inquiry and you go
how is this not already vr
then you know and and and i think that
that that is the essence of where um
the modernized world is pushing
and that the modernized world is going
to triangulate on the exact same
realization
that five thousand years ago four
thousand years ago three thousand years
ago from
everywhere across the world it's a
perennial spiritual wisdom
um it has been triangulating on so so um
we'll see and i and i do think that john
smart's transcension hypothesis has a
lot of um
of potential uh as well um
we've hit on so many awesome things i
want to um
um i want to talk about this for a bit i
think that you know
you've had incredible guests on your
show already i highly recommend
you guys to go and check out james's
podcast he's crushing it check out his
youtube channel
um christophe [ __ ] episode was so good
so was um
you know donald huffman both such great
episodes
if we take um if we take hoffman's
perspective for a little bit we were
talking about this a lit a bit before we
started
um it seems like a multimodal
user interface and the video game
analogy we were just talking about a
moment ago
um those are basically
anyone that has anyone that goes through
that process of self-inquiry we were
just talking about
inevitably comes to the realization that
they themselves
have a uh a user interface that they
are they're in a reality they have a
they have this user interface
there are um there are fitness functions
you know that if you
if you eat um a bucket
of ice cream um you're gonna feel like
[ __ ]
and that you're gonna feel like [ __ ] the
next day and that you're probably
shaving
um could be shaving a day or two or even
a week off of your longevity
um and now versus if you eat a salad
you're gonna feel great you'll feel
great tomorrow you'll
you might you know have an extra week on
so there's there's
there are um there are these
these understandings of um of what you
do
in this in this reality um is going to
inevitably um make you more peaceful
more happy uh
a better mate more knowledge about
truth more um uh a better
better mate for procreation so the the
the i and i'm i'm also curious where
living mirrors theory could potentially
um synthesis with the multimodal
user interface because in a sense that's
what the cell
does have the cell has a a
allege a ledger an understanding of of
the world and then it's constantly
updating that based on
fitness so do you see a synthesis of of
hoffman and and you and in a sense as
well i can see your headphonics
yeah i um so i think that's a really
really important point so
um yeah i would say once so when i was
an undergrad when i first was kind of
introduced to psychology and
neuroscience it was taught
kind of um that it was kind of a fact or
it's almost a
point of definition that colors are not
out there in the world
beauty is not out there in the world
things are not objectively colorful
objectively beautiful
um those are qualities that exist in
consciousness and this was just like
day one of like talking about perception
let's get our definitions straight
if your leaves are not green you
perceive them to be green
but that's that's in consciousness right
um so when i first saw donald hoffman's
theory it took me a while just to
understand what he was saying was
radical
because when when he says case against
reality his name his book
and he was saying the world isn't
actually full of these colors i was like
well that's that's a fact basically like
i think if you're thinking about the
world the right way is that's
that's something yeah that's true but
then
it turns out he's saying something far
more radical that like you know the moon
isn't there when you're not looking at
it that kind of thing i think there's
something
even though it's not um it doesn't have
the same appearance like appearances
happen in consciousness i think there's
some structure
out there in the world that persists
when when we're not looking at it but
um but yeah so so this idea that
conscious the contents of consciousness
are absolutely
and i was basically only tied to fitness
payoffs is the term that hoffman uses
but like um so there's structure in the
world
and you perceive you know when you're
hungry you perceive
certain food to be appetizing and
delicious
and when you're not hungry you know if
you eat too much chocolate then the same
thing can now appear disgusting right
like your conscious perception
the attribute of the thing in the world
has changed yet it's not like physicists
have to account for some
you know um some atom that decays
from like nice atom to disgusting atom
you know
that's not how we think about the kind
of disgustingness or appetizing-ness of
the chocolate being out there in the
world
same's true for color seems true uh for
all these other things which is
you know that that's that was the way i
was thinking about consciousness when i
came up with my theory because
in my theories it's absolutely entirely
tied up with the organism's survival
and the contents of consciousness are
completely tied up with with what you
might call
fitness payoffs um and also i think to
just get a feeling of this kind of
the fact that what you perceive as an
interface for the world you know like
um if you perceive you know based on
your history and your kind of genetics
and stuff you might perceive
certain foods to be appealing because
because of that history and because it
makes sense for you
in the same way like you know imagine if
as well as us becoming this intelligent
technologically advanced civilization
imagine if slugs had as well
and you had you know slug hollywood
celebrities
who all the slugs agreed were the most
beautiful
perfect you know things they thought
they were like objectively beautiful i
don't think i would be agreeing that
these like hollywood celebrities are
objectively
beautiful right and that's that's a way
of seeing that the perception the
conscious
perception of beauty is is not out there
in the world and
and as weird as it sounds it's true for
all of our
our senses and we saw this with the the
hysteria around um
that dress that went viral with the
color can i talk to you about it
beautiful good thank you for example i
was very excited when
that came up so i was like this is what
i'm interested in and this points to
something fascinating about the nature
of reality
exactly like you're poised on
understanding something
but then then the media kind of took it
in a far more like no no it's just this
this kind of you know some more kind of
a less radical kind of
ways it's like the biggest metaphysical
thing and yeah
exactly exactly and it and it's what you
can do from that point and the same
thing was with that um
that sound clip of yanny versus laurel
people heard it as these two different
words right
what you can realize that is that what
you're seeing is not
perception is not like you're looking
out of these transparent eyeballs to
a freestanding world james just one
quick
um available on uh you can go back and
forth but on the
um uh the dress i
you can't at least um from what i've
tested with people
they can't go back and forth between
gold and white
and black and blue which that i think is
the most profound part of of it yeah
anyway
uh yeah i mean yeah it's never that's
interesting in its own right i think it
might be to do with the fact that
like with the with the vase face
illusion where it kind of changes
there's some structure there that you
can scan your attention around and you
can
you have some model in your head of the
two things and you can you can kind of
actively engage with the process same
with the annie and laurel
you can really try and focus on the high
notes that sound like yanny
and all the low notes and laurel with
the dress it's more i think
the the thing that seems to account for
which way you go is
is if you think you're discounting blue
light or
yellow light i read one thing that's i
don't know if it was actually
uh real data or if it's just speculation
but there was this speculation that
that men would see it um
as i think it was black and blue oh no
sorry yellow and
um gold and white because they played
more computer games with blue lights so
their brain
is used to being like oh like the room's
drenched in blue light i better discount
some blue
and then it pushes it in that direction
um but uh
yeah i mean i don't know if that's
that's was actually proven but that's i
think that might be why it moves that
way
but uh but yeah so what it shows you
though is that this is not a pre-given
world that looks the way it looks
there is a screen of this consciousness
and there's all these weird appearances
inside it
and you are you are just another one of
these appearances you know when i'm
looking at my hand
it feels like this hand is inside me but
actually it's appearing in consciousness
it's it's visually continuous with the
rest of the background
and that's when you can your kind of
sense of self and blink out of existence
and there can just be this
kind of light of consciousness and a
bunch of phenomena happening and you can
realize that
fundamentally that's what's going on and
there's a delusion when you
you you know you take this bundle of
perceptions and you say this is me
these appearances of hands are me and
you know i'm saying there is an organism
but the organism is not the same thing
as the concept of the self
and it's the concept of the self that
all of our suffering is is fed through
you know this was the kind of buddha's
insight
that neuroscience is now kind of showing
to be true as well right
so it could be fair to say that there
is a um within the
living mirror theory there is a
um uh the living system
has its uh a coupling with the
environment and
in that process the multimodal user
interface is what the living system uses
so there's that that's kind of what the
synthesis
could yeah and i would say just kind of
important to
the interface ideas that's important
because consciousness is not like you're
being aware of the thing out there
what it is is the thing out there is
utterly beyond your boundary you know
your hair is this kind of bounded
physical system photons might fall on
your retina
but you know your insides your brain
everything else is just utterly in the
dark
and so consciousness is this active
creative
generative kind of hallucinatory process
and when you understand that the world
doesn't have an appearance it kind of
gives you
an appreciation as to why it's possible
for consciousness to exist
because it's not it's not like um
there's a thing
and i have a symbol for the thing and
how does my symbol become conscious
that's how a lot of people think about
this stuff
you know it's the kind of computer
analogy it's like there's some symbol
over here and there's some real thing
over here like say that there's a green
object and there's a symbol saying green
why does this symbol become
conscious whereas in a computer it
doesn't why doesn't the word green when
i write it down
why doesn't that become conscious
whereas i'm saying no like there is no
green thing
there's patterns and then you
consciousness is fundamentally you're
generating yeah like a simulation
generating an interface of beliefs about
the way the world is that it's this kind
of house of cards of like
uh saying it's this way as opposed to
this way so it's entirely
uh generated within the organism well
through interacting with this
environment
but it's it's not um each
each percept is is only cashed out in
reference to all the other percepts it's
this like relativistic framework
i've i've really appreciated um a way of
um of perceiving it regarding um
when you're when you're under when
you're at a
uh an event where you're you know you're
you're at whether it does literally just
take any
uh sports or music style event in a
stadium
and you're gonna have a different
point of view than somebody sitting
across the stadium
and when when you also register
that um you're gonna get that
at a at a deeper level that it's not
some um
uh that that you in when
all you got to play game i feel like you
gotta if you
really dive in like we didn't have the
tool of games
we had it but we didn't have you know
this is the game changer
is that when you it's literally the
screen like the screen
as an analogy the game as an analogy to
this is exactly what makes us
realize that when i go into the
the the the first person perspective
in in in and i'm playing and i'm playing
the game and i'm and i'm walking around
in the in the simulated world and i have
this
the the relationship between me as a
living system and my environment and my
interface and all of the
all of the stuff that i have in my
parcel that i'm my that i'm carrying
around with me
and that i have these quests and these
objectives and
that the more that you kind of follow
that uh train of thinking the more that
you're gonna realize that
james is also a player
and james also has his little um
world that that james is playing in as
well and james is going to see things
like
you are you is it is that it are you is
that your
girlfriend or is that the fiance or wife
what level or
life yeah life okay wife wife what's her
name
hey rebecca rebecca so um that you know
you have a wife you
have you know you have a wife you have a
rebecca like you you have
like you have that in your life i don't
have like a wife
so like my like the fact that we like
that you have a wife and i don't like
that is like a significant reality
changer
and so um like that's like that's
something to like
keep in mind like somebody that's living
in a completely different country
is basically on in a sense their reality
has a significantly different um
like you're in you're mostly in london
and in the mountains of portugal
and so you're you're inevitably going to
have
a different map than uh california in
the midwest
and stuff like that so um but but but
there's also
there's some there's a synthesis between
if we don't break it down
in two there's a synthesis where it's
like in order for us to
um have the zoom call we have to respect
the objectivity of the science that is
occurring
that is enabling the um the the
computation
the um the the electromagnetic
communication um
so you you you you have a a synthesis
that's going on if we want to agree that
the h2o molecule
um looks a specific way or that the the
cellular respiration and um and the
oxygen cycle on the planet happens
a specific way for for for every person
that
inhales the though too i think that that
there's gonna be a synthesis between
those
um those individual gamers
uh in their worlds with the fact that
all of those gamers are inhaling
um o2 and their hearts are beating a
hundred thousand times a day
stuff like that yeah i think um and also
the idea of being the kind of gamer with
the headset on you you mentioned earlier
the kind of
simulation stuff um which obviously is
the name of the podcast as well so maybe
it's relevant to
touch on that um but yeah i think i
think it's interesting that i i guess
it's not something i've dwell on very
much because um i think it's the uh
the thing we spoke about before where i
was saying like as a scientist it's like
i'll map out what what's within my
domain like so the before the big bang
we might be you know i mentioned earlier
ways of thinking about
why anything's happening at all and i'm
happy to speculate about that
but then you know like what happened for
the big bang is just kind of outside my
window
um what you know what happens in the
future is as well
uh so i i think like i guess i see
science as mapping out
this little space we're in now and most
people think it's the entire space right
they think big bang
this thing and that's it i i suspect
there's you know like why wouldn't there
be vast amounts of stuff going on
outside of
our window i see no you know reason why
you wouldn't think
whether you want to call it multiverses
or simulations within simulations within
simulations to me that seems
absolutely you know if not um plausible
likely you know that something
weird is happening um before
uh i think before certain psychedelic
experiences i would have said there's no
reason to
speculate like it's just it's
speculation it's like saying
am i a solipsist and then you can have
experiences where you seem to wake up
from the simulation and
that that definitely gives you that kind
of strange loop
idea of like wait like is this some is
there simulations all the way down and
you know you can kind of tumble through
them through some way but i think i
ultimately come back to kind of knowing
my place as a scientist and
thinking i'm gonna if this is a
simulation it's a
beautiful pretty complex simulation
that's really relevant
for our day-to-day living so i'm gonna
try and understand this one as best as i
can
if at the end i wake up take my headset
off and go wow i can't believe that was
a game
uh i don't think i'll have i'll feel
like i've wasted my time in trying to
trying to understand the game yeah
and which plays very beautifully into
what we
mentioned uh earlier on uh infinity
making a infinite amount of illusory
finity and that plays into the
multiverse um perfectly
um there's just and and it also plays
perfectly in the sense of if you believe
in yourself as infinite potential that
there
is um every single possibility of you
and uh is happening right now and and
also every single possibility
in a in a non-uh anthropocentric way
is also happening so when you see all of
these designer
worlds that the video game artists are
making
all of those are happening as well and
we ourselves
are going to become more and more like
designers of worlds and we ourselves are
going to come to the realization more
and more of what infinity
truly is yeah
i think that that thing you said about
nature as infinite possibility
like i've been reflecting recently on
i've not tried to put this into words
but
there's a so i i don't believe i believe
that kind of
organism level um to use that term uh
libertarian free will the idea that you
know we can we can really choose exactly
what we want to do with no prior causes
kind of causing it i think that's an
illusion and it's a kind of
it's trying to kind of make ourselves
feel comfortable in our in our feeling
of separation but if you look at
the kind of the the freedom of the
totality of existence
and you consider the way that particles
interact and
anything happens from that perspective
everything the way that things interact
is the perfect choice given what they
are
like this is kind of what a scientific
picture of the world is it's like a
lawful thing it's like
given these things and their forces and
and what they are in themselves
they will the universe is utterly free
to do
exactly what is the most like lawful
or most um appropriate thing for it to
do
so you can think of of when you identify
with all of reality as there being this
kind of
ultimate freedom ultimate creative
fulfillment of the process just just
moving forward
in terms of what it is and what's best
for what it is which is another way of
describing determinism
which is a weird thing to say is that
like that you know from one side from
the human
idea of separation the idea of the
universe deciding everything is like oh
no that seems scary
that seems like you know i don't like
that idea but the idea of
the universe being ultimately free and
therefore manifesting its
what is most within its own nature is i
think is a really
yeah it it to me gives a scientific wave
maybe it's the scientific language
heading to what you just said about
identifying that kind of infinite
potential identifying with that
and you're spot on too and i'm i'm glad
that you
made content again everybody check out
james's channel
i'm glad that you made content
specifically about your
anthogenic experiences i think that's
extremely important the more that
um people feel like they are comfortable
it's almost like we're having a species
coming out of the closet in a sense
around
around the use of uh unleashing the
divine within via these
sacred secretions um of the planet and
and it's it's extremely important i'm
glad that you've made content about it
you've been vulnerable about i think
that's very important
um and that's also going to triangulate
right on that that same
nature of reality what what are you and
rebecca doing with um the homestead
um surrender homestead what are you guys
doing with that um
i know you you guys are just starting
with it
and like it it sounds so beautiful like
literally when i was researching
you um i went to like i started like
google earthing portugal and like
looking at where
like where like and i was looking at
like the temperatures and the culture
and the gdp and the living standards and
like it's beautiful like it's amazing
i've been
hopefully you saw why we chose that yeah
yeah yeah so tell us about
the surrender homestead yes so um
it fits very much with what you just
said about how um
you know like i don't i guess i'm not
fundamentally identified as a scientist
who's doing this
i'm fundamentally just a person who's
trying to be honest about
what i see as important in the world and
when it comes to
for me like being open about spiritual
stuff was also
a kind of taboo in this kind of
scientific circles i moved in
but i kind of i think it's just within
me that i
think i've always had just a feeling of
if i hold true to what i think is
authentic and real and and you know like
and true and i'm just truthful about it
um if people don't get it or if culture
isn't is isn't ready then culture isn't
ready like that's not my problem you
know if i'm
if i take some magic mushrooms and
society says that's an illegal activity
that's bad you know i can give up i can
absolutely give account as to why i do
it why
i think it's it's not harmful why i
think it's incredibly beneficial right
so
that's also that same logic and the same
with vulnerability you know with trying
to
you know i want to live in a world where
especially feel like men can can be more
vulnerable emotionally
and it would be it'd be a bit rich for
me to not then put myself out there
and say like look this is this is who i
am i you know i'm gonna try and live
from a place of truth
um and yeah so it makes a life a lot
easier as well if you just
if you just don't hold anything back um
so then when it comes to surrender
homestead
we have a bunch of different ideas of
what we want to do we'd love to maybe
host retreats
like you know maybe ayahuasca retreats
stuff like that um
we also my wife really wants it to be a
kind of artist residency a place people
can come and just create and just have
them like studios and
we're just in nature so people can just
kind of connect with nature and and all
that kind of good stuff
but yeah we're in we're in the early
stages we're kind of renovating we
bought this big bit of land we're
renovating an old an old farmhouse
but the fact that we kind of find
ourselves here is
really because of the same thing we just
spoke about and
because my wife's in the same wavelength
of being like well
we're humans you know humans are these
creatures that are born into nature
we're supposed to be in nature we're
supposed to create
like this is what's good for us to
exercise you know be in the sunshine
and we spent our years you know in
london and these places like
you know you know working hard to
establish ourselves
but there was always this feeling of
like society is a bit of a crazy
it's it's sick in many ways i would say
and so the fact that we find ourselves
here is fundamentally
living from that place of authenticity
of being like this is where we we would
prefer to be
well and and the thing you said of like
potential like we know
being here will lead to something good
like we may not be able to say
next year we're going to hold an
ayahuasca retreat or next year we're
going to be open to accept artists for
residency but we know something's going
to happen we know
people you know like we're at a
beautiful location we have you know
intention to share it with people in
some capacity so so yeah keep it keep an
eye on i think the surrender homestead
on instagram is our best
place to keep up with us um if you want
to see us assembling composting toilets
and stuff like that as well
so so beautifully said we have the
economic machinery that is uh producing
so much excellence and also so much
deterioration and so to
wake up to archiving the codes that are
deteriorating and amplifying the codes
that are
making things better in that machinery
and also building you know cities 2.0
because people love urban centers so
time to build those up into the 2.0
category
and also um especially with arcology
bringing together architecture and
ecology but
sustainability but also having places
where we literally
just go no like like
i don't want to be in city 2.0
i want to be in um
in extreme i want to be in the most
extreme
nature setting like sometimes we've
envisioned this on the show where you
literally can take
like could you could you take and build
out
um a beautiful like augmented reality
creative space in the middle of the
redwoods in california
um or right on the pacific ocean um or
the atlantic and portugal you know
there's
there's all of these interesting ways to
like embed
um kind of the like and you can just
turn
off that augmented reality space
whenever you want and you're
just back at the pacific or the atlantic
or the redwoods or whatever
so um it like to be able to
instantaneously
ebb and flow between the the two
is is going to be very important i'm
excited that you guys are building it
out i think it's very it's a very
important project from the heart to do
and you want to share which is very
important and you're going to you're
gonna inspire a lot of people by doing
that
um you already inspired me and many
viewers by doing that and hopefully
you know follow along on on instagram
and uh and maybe
within you know who knows 2021 could be
some sort of cool
um opening of of a yeah of an event or
you know i love our artists and
residencies are going to be very
important um
just briefly on the scientific dogma
i think spirituality also has spiritual
dogma
where there's no interest in science
um and the scientific method uh so i
think that when you go
extreme uh kairos on spirituality
you lose all kronos and when you go
extreme kronos on science you lose all
kairos
of uh spirituality and so those dogmatic
circles
um need to in a sense realize that they
do not represent the essence of the
nature of reality which is to drop the
silos and to more harmoniously merge
um so that's in essence what the science
and spirituality and that's why you're
doing what you're doing and why we're
doing what we're doing because
yeah there is no dividing into two it's
it is just the one
yeah i think um that's also yeah a
really good point that
again all these things are maps you know
like the
reality has no there is no god's eye
view where we can say
this is the correct answer it turns out
science is right or turns out
spirituality is right
they're different angles different
perspectives like you were saying in the
stadium like
you're looking at this this beautiful
diamond of existence from all these
different angles
and i think again i think it's the the
this the pro the process of creation and
control and separation is can often be
the thing that fuels kind of fear and
and
investment in the identity and tribalism
and and
basically like i'm a scientist over here
because i feel uncomfortable when people
talk about
woowoo spirituality stuff so i'm gonna
just assume it's all nonsense and
you know and then we hold on to our
world views like these blankets right
and we're not
and again that's what we spoke about
earlier with consciousness and like i
think it's gonna be a real uphill battle
to
to convince this generation of
scientists
that that plants might be conscious
there are lots of plant scientists who
think
think they are but um yeah i think there
was a stephen hawking quote that i'm not
going to be able to remember but it was
something to do with like
like uh scientific revolutions only
happened when like each generation
dies effectively like when there's a new
generation coming up to to hear new
ideas are fresh and
you know take them on board and again i
think that's because of this emotional
attachment
um quite early i guess to ideas
my gosh the blanket analogy
is very strong there it is it's uh
it's the sense of uh of really being
warm like it's almost like not wanting
to get out of
bed in the morning because that that
blanket is so
warm and if you take the blanket off
and you expose yourself to the
the the force is the cold um
in in the sense of you're on the you're
on the hunt again
to try and augment the blankets
and try and make a really strong hammock
for for you to be able to you know lay
in and enjoy
it it's it's good to think of of
yourself as as
wanting to and the same thing with the
layers of the onion
is another way to view is like do you
shed
each one of those layers and get back to
what is the most fundamental
of our existence that shared
consciousness shared awareness
and that also that is the
the the realization
slowly that we have the different maps
of science spirituality
yeah it's been it's been really solid
back and forth on this and
i james another thing is i just really
appreciate the fact that
um one of the things with this big
synthesis that i'm passionate about is
just
at least um whether
i'm right or i'm wrong
at least i have tried that's what's most
important i think
because with um living mirror theory of
consciousness
it's the same thing every single person
whether they're ultimately you know
right or wrong or
that they're at least moving the
foundation of thinking forward
they're ultimately at least trying
and in order to break through from being
like
the fear right like wayne gretzky if
you're gonna miss every shot you don't
take you have to take the shots
so you're gonna take the we're gonna
take these shots
and at least we're going to push further
so
i just congratulate the fact that you
pushed and made this and that you're
publishing and that you're going to move
forward with it
on experientially with proving
hypotheses
so thank you for inspiring people um
to to do so
thank you but it's interesting because i
i maybe it's because i've been so
weighted towards that side of
creating like that but where my head is
at now is actually kind of on
emphasizing the other side of it which
is the kind of being you know we were
talking about this division between
kind of striving becoming like doing and
i um in the past i would have been i
would have very gladly just said
like thank you very much you know like
that's uh you know
nice to be recognized for that but where
i'm at now is i would say like
um most people like if we if we had more
people
who were interested in the experiential
side of things like cultivating
compassion working through their own
traumas and stuff like
i could i could happily live in a world
without science without
where we kind of moved back to a far
simpler way of life you know just like
living close to nature
um you know so i don't believe in
progress for for progress his own sake
and it's interesting that i i see in
myself and in a lot of other scientists
i think a kind of um we spoke about the
kind of emotional
currents underpinning science i think a
lot of people get interested in
kind of science and philosophy of things
like consciousness comes out of some
quite
deep existential anguish of some kind
you know and i think for me though there
was a kind of
very early kind of being physically
unsafe as a child was kind of like is
what
made me just be like okay what's going
on i need to figure out what's going on
and suddenly you're living up in your
head and you're like
your mind is racing to figure out what's
going on in the world
and i think this isn't something i see
spoken about the i think a lot of
very talented philosophers very talented
scientists
also like should be when it comes to
like psychedelic medicine being made
legal
they should be like high up on the list
of people to tap on the shoulder and go
like
good work figure out all that stuff but
maybe you want to go and
have a bit of psilocybin therapy and see
if there might be some some fire that's
that's driving you unconsciously
and that maybe you might be happier
without your mind racing all the time
because for me that's that's kind of
what's happened and that's why i'm here
really is
is moving you know i'm still continuing
to communicate
and think about this stuff and i'm not
just gonna you know switch off from the
science but i i definitely
this is coming from someone who i think
has always been a bit imbalanced and
is finding balance and and sees we live
in a culture that praises progress so
much that i think it's worth saying that
like it's not
physically valuable it's you know it
comes in a in a context of
striving for because you're not happy i
think
beautifully beautifully put that yes
we're gonna
have a a long-term synthesis of
as you can say like the masculine the
feminine the science the spirituality
the uh the kairos with the chronos like
it's just
inevitably um going to be uh
a deeper more harmony harmony is always
this key word a harmony
harmony um okay let's wrap um
beautiful like man i just i i'm just so
passionate about the inquiry that you
have um and that it's inspiring me and i
hope
other people as well and and also it's
balanced with
the also the deep uh the
press that you've had to to to embody
from
in your in your heart and to to to
explore what has
be who are you individually and what has
been what has affected you and
um i think that i think that you are in
fact a
very beautiful person that you have a
very beautiful story that you have a
like james i'm very grateful thank you
for coming on the program yeah
for that i'll say thanks very much no
qualification for me on that that way
i'm so i'm so grateful that we got this
chance to to talk and to
get to know each other deeper i'm super
grateful and yeah
yeah yeah and i would i would highly uh
suggest everybody thank you for tuning
in first of all we greatly appreciate
you thank you
thank you um do your best uh
to to to tune into what james is
putting out james says so many good
links now in his bio go and check those
out he's got his website
where he's got all of his resources um
but also he has
his youtube channel excellent
conversations check those out
also the reality sandwich profile is
very good where he has his writings
the writings are very short and sweet
and they get to the point and
um i think you you are you're you have a
very strong synthesis ability which i i
like a lot of compression
of key points um so check those out
everybody
also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the scientists the
spiritual leaders in your communities
that you believe and support them and
help them flourish
you can find all the links to simulation
in the bio below if you'd like to
help support us and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much
thank you for tuning in we'll see you
soon
peace
[Music]
you